[Music]
in what type are you news submitted by
gta5 [ __ ] criminal type yeah I'm a
Type O is it about personality types
this is all just all your realm right
here int J I am a ENTJ I think what I
don't know I can't remember it I take it
every time someone asked me and it's int
J and then I take it some other day and
it's ENTJ so I'm like in between
extrovert introvert it's [ __ ] but
the ntj always stays the same
hey David you must be a Capricorn I'm a
Santa Square a sex therapist helps you
understand your type of sex drive type
of sex I like ass
I like ass so she's like any business
from you simple man right there like
what's your sex type look get you going
I'll take big booty [ __ ] and titties
yeah sure can't do much with them can't
do much for them
I like what the titties the chess ass
yeah they can feed babies Yeah right
well if the actual the the actual reason
for them what do you mean well you can
city [ __ ] yeah but it's not that great
have you done it yeah done it no it's
why me you're the weird one yeah of
course I have some titties out there
that are [ __ ] afraid of me all along
let's just say that cuz I really gave it
to him yeah I did you oh yeah really do
really big time believing on the inner
part of their chest dance
that's how do
you want a chest boat after this [ __ ]
now just Halloween David loved that one
this stuff finish the boat but ask these
together and titties they just kind of
floppy you like really gonna work a
little bit hard to have to do this or
the guy and this just a lot of woman
no but the fun part is the ending shoots
right here the girl doesn't like it see
that's I'm saying the coal doesn't like
Elmo it doesn't feel good for us it's
like okay it's more of a fetish thing
and you want to do it just to violate
the body like a territorial yes and then
once you get it you're good then why
does the girl moan because it's for you
yeah it's for you man it's a girl
formance it's like what a girl sucks a
dick as she moans is because it makes
you feel yeah oh my mouth feel the mayo
now my mouth is orgasming I thought it
did Wow you guys we have the same type
of mouths if you have put your mouth on
a dick it wouldn't spot alike guys you
don't need to like back well you but you
guys but you guys love dick you [ __ ]
love it we need it that's what porn
tells me scarcity did you know that wait
what does it feel like titty titty-fuck
[ __ ] it feels like unnecessary work
that's what that feels like that's true
no it feels like I don't know makes two
good things happen it's like it's like
you're [ __ ] a warm mousepad yeah it's
just different it's different and work
for this amount of play I would know
that TIFF look at me
I wouldn't know that hey TIFF a lot of
mouse pads out there pretty afraid of me
just just to put it it's like this is
like for me it's like vagina blow job
hand job tit job agreed that's how low
tit job there's a girl with some big-ass
tits it might be different nah man cuz I
still she still has to hold it up it
doesn't do anything for her no she's
just I'm just in the weird position I
hate it it's not good visuals going on
in the head and your dick will be cold
all the time
we didn't right now watching this and
going well you haven't got tipped back
by me are you true and I haven't but I'm
but I get it I really got the lubricate
to right yeah yeah it's not good unless
it's like lubricator yeah you don't have
to lubricate it you don't have to but it
feels better sex tight I will tell you
not Teddy [ __ ] Mel please so there
are two different types of sex drives
there is a spontaneous desire and a
responsive desire so it's pretty much
being like mentally interested in sex
versus being physically ready for it
it's like if you're the type of person
that first like just out of the blue you
know you're doing your thing and then
all of a sudden you start thinking about
sex and you're like whoo I want sex
right now and so you're thinking about
it and your mind is prepared for it
first or you that's mainly it seems like
statistically guys are that type so
first they want to think about sex and
that's how they're ready for sex when
they're thinking about it don't want to
is just we think about sex all the time
okay well that's I'm not thinking about
sex right now why not cuz I cuz I have
self-control
so we're reversed I guess oh I think
about sex all the [ __ ] time
yeah so so this they're saying that 75%
of men and 15% of women have spontaneous
desire so the other way what was it
spontaneous desire any % of 175 percent
of men and 15% of women oh that's why
there's always like the the the story of
girls Vaughn I'm not in the mood I've
already been picking about it for you so
you guys are mentally ready right so
then the other one is responsive desire
and this is five percent of men and
thirty percent of women so this is when
you it was only thirty five percent of
people well I mean there's their dude
show you the other one but you get to be
an understand them figures okay
there's so much to it okay
they're saying is the responsive desire
is that you don't really get ready for
sex
until after you've already done some
physical actions like making out or
you've done for play then you're then
your mind catches up to what your body's
feeling and then that's when you're
ready for sex so they're saying that
there are you to both I don't know I
feel like I go back and forth between a
lot of woods there are a lot of people
so they did say that 20 percent of men
and 55 percent of women experience a bit
of both yeah because like sometimes out
of nowhere I'm just horny and I'm like
oh my god and I can't something in my
section I want to have sex sometimes I'm
like I need to go to sleep but I didn't
want to masturbate to go to sleep but
I'm not really a horny so then I start
thinking about it to stimulate and then
a lutely have to masturbate to sleep
6:00 in the morning but not tired at
10:00 but I want to get eight hours of
sleep so thank you master yeah so that I
knew they'd just not see well like
self-soothing yeah and it's not really
like I can't sleep yeah yeah that's like
your pacifier so it's different from
like wanting to yeah like I'm not horny
I just like need to sleep so that's so
tight you don't need sleeping pills you
got jack off yeah that's [ __ ] Thanks
me too but it's a little different
because I'm so desensitized to jerking
off that I have to suck my own dick to
go to sleep but I do it a lot this is
not good what would that category fall
under kiss that's that's me for sure so
they are saying that it's not like one
type of sex drive is better than the
other or one has it easier than the
other because they're saying that like
if you are a spontaneous desire the
one-night first your mind is ready
sometimes those are the people because
it's men sometimes they're the ones that
have trouble getting ready for sex
because their bodies aren't that's mean
it's usually their mind that's their
first so then it takes them a little
longer to get their body to react to
what their mind is thinking or the other
way around where it's like well you know
for women we have to for statistically
it's mainly like responsive desires
kinda have to like be physically turned
on first and then your mind catches up
to what your body's I'm definitely more
the first one then the second one which
one was the first one your before your
body yeah so your mind is there but your
body's not like reacting where's my mind
and body are there but my wife has cold
hands where's my mind my mind and body
is there but it's a public restroom and
Steve thinks it's gross that's true
[ __ ] disgusting aches and [ __ ] but it
smells in there and it's just like
smells not bad would you do - boy yes
you would that's a hook shot Steve green
three twice yes exactly
there's so many factors to think about
in a dirty bathroom there's only two
times dirtier it's what holds the sink
where it's you know cool in dog you
wanna [ __ ] in the bathroom at Cheesecake
Factory all right cuz yeah that would be
quite nice it's like it Barstow
at a restaurant yeah dude with the
[ __ ] metal toilets with no toilet
seat [ __ ] you in the Cheesecake Factory
bathrooms cuz you know what you could
you could [ __ ] Dookie and piss and
wet toilet paper on the floor right you
better [ __ ] them in a Japanese
restaurant [ __ ] that's where you
should do it no here's the good places
to [ __ ] in a public restroom is like
where it you could lock the door it's
supposed to be for one for the whole
room yeah Japanese restaurants even if
they know that you're having sex in
there they'll apologize to you at a
sushi restaurant cuz they're hardcore
present matter would never happen yeah I
did cuz she it's by the way that is such
a [ __ ] thing she just forgot cuz she
has definitely seen my ass like many
times no she forgot like I would never
forget that but remember I'm trying to
forget that visual right now started out
nice in the now and I'm picturing your
ass right now it's pretty nice yeah firm
yeah we're all pitching your but I think
Bart's but at all because I've seen it
so many times I really seen Steve's but
once so whenever I pictured it's only in
the one spot that I've seen it like only
in the doorway between our bathroom and
in-between what's the weight so after
you guys [ __ ] let's say you have to go
to the bat the first you told a
Shutterfly guys take his underwear off
I'm not gonna all the time I do oh you
were you wear briefs we sheets over you
is it like that
no [ __ ] no I don't give a [ __ ] no it's
usually okay so I have really big balls
right so when my balls like swing too
much get spray can get pretty nuts on my
body
and so I try to keep them coming to
contain so that it doesn't hurt me to
[ __ ] move up that makes sense thank
you well sometimes when you [ __ ] after a
really hot shower and those things are
looses alright and you're trying to
smash from the back that [ __ ] hurts like
old lady's coin purse what did they
create let's sort of like nut holding
fat like a thong you think I haven't
been begging for Kickstarter for right
now right Dean came in a letter every
week they invented the Segway and I'm
like yo invent me a ball brought please
Jane Jane yes so when she's on top it
still hurts your nuts we get on top baby
I like to control them I like it with
Tom and Amy and he likes to dominate so
yeah there's no point really I like
falling asleep I lay there just waking
up and coming like what the [ __ ] it's a
different feeling though you know that
totally different feeling well you could
control on the body though right I like
to feel held down I can't go anywhere
yeah he can't hold you down like this
right no my that's true rabbis yeah the
thighs border them straight was your
hammies and keep going keep going
yes they're really strong so I think I
feel like I could get away from on top
you could get away from me yeah I don't
think you can break we're gonna try it
yeah do it do it tonight takes us to the
yearbook not gonna like it no I do
anything with this [ __ ] oh boy there
you go not public restrooms
[Music]